is it just me or is anybody else having extreme fluctuations in their personal energy
like feeling extremely manic
go go go go 1min and then completely collapsing the next
I started off pretty strong yesterday and then collapsed in the afternoon
I took two naps on the couch and I never take naps
and I was asleep by 11 after taking two naps and then I slept for 12h
12h after two naps on the couch
I seriously had to force myself to get out of bed because I could have slept another 12
I know we're talking about ascension symptoms earth two
this human resonance frequency has been over double its normal frequency
and we've been having extreme solar flares
these things are affecting the human body
and you're not alone